good morning John we'd like to have a
pretty positive attitude here at
vlogbrothers but once a year once a year
I like to get furious for not really
great reasons but today is that day this
year John today I'm going to have 17
rants in four minutes this whatever I
recognize that it is food and don't mind
putting it on a sandwich every once in a
while but craft do not call this cheese
that is not the texture the smell the
taste or consistency of cheese calling
it American cheese is an insult to both
my country and my second favorite kind
of food speaking of food 90% fat-free
does not mean that it is any % fat-free
it means it's 10% fat to just say that
10% fat dear people who complain about
the chemicals that they're exposed to
everything is chemicals water your body
omega-3 fatty acids raspberries
chemicals continuing on this theme stop
saying all-natural when you mean healthy
because there's lots of all-natural
things that like I don't sit down and
like eat a tub of lard while marathoning
Firefly but that would be all-natural
what the crap is up with this kind of
toilet paper like I want to know who the
diabolical turd face was who decided to
promote the discomfort of all mankind
with this harsh non perforated flimsy
terribleness speaking of public
restrooms if you pee on the seat any
amount clean it up you terrible person
it's your pee and someone is going to
have to clean it up but if it's not you
they will be cleaning up someone else's
pee people who think that not knowing
every bit of a fandoms trivia makes you
not a fan well oh I guess you were just
born with a deep and intense knowledge
of the backstory of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer
where are you not at one time unexcited
knob it's just like the person you are
currently insulting do you really need
to ruin that for the Mogar you were
turning oh if only there'd been some way
for you to signal your a debt to do that
stop correcting people for saying Jif or
gif wrong they are
with correct pronunciations by telling
someone they are doing it wrong
you are the only person who is wrong 3
gig good jump is so much ketchup it
depart I knowed you saying you saying
Hank why don't you just get the
squeezable kind yeah that's perfect if I
want to spray some pink ketchup piss all
over my fries
come on manufacturers of chair wheels
everywhere should have got this ready
before with the Jeremiah frickin Knotts
freaking water they always not do you
please make it so that this doesn't fit
in this because this is the worst thing
you're still using gay is an insult it's
not just really insulting to gay people
it also makes you sound really immature
and kind of stupid you so stop and
finally to all the people who are going
to complain about me complaining in this
video because we all have it so good
yes I recognize that I am a wealthy
person in the wealthiest country at the
wealthiest moment so far in human
history but nonetheless somehow it still
hurts when I stop my dough and I'm still
annoyed when the freaking check out
thing asks me for the dead time if I
have scanned my called card no I haven't
standby club card you know how I know
because you're still asking me your
passive-aggressive robot Sakic ketchupy
gaff I don't know at the end of this
video a lot of people have told me that
it's good to get out your anger every
once in a while but I've read research
that in fact the angrier you are the
more angry you become so this actually
is a bad idea don't do the thing I just
did because now my heart rates all up
and I just want to be right about
everything
I'll see you on Tuesday John